taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah I'll just say
hey everybody it's time for t-a-s-t-e
buds Joe DeRosa is still on a walkabout
somewhere oh but I have a special guest
today a very special guest my good
friend the hysterical and the one of a
kind Mr Eric Andre is here today doing
America wow we're trying to get in for a
while you do a pot too right I'm very
difficult to work with brother
I just asked what's the worst you've
ever bummed oh well then we won't do
that now because then I'll do it on
yours because I have one I wanna you can
give me a little taste I could I could
pick one of my 10 bombs I don't know
give me more stages because I have
genuine curiosity but then come on my
show and Retail it okay okay uh let me
think of a really really bad one I can't
believe the Ross is not [__] here for
me that is such a slap
exactly he's driving with no intention
do you know that he's just driving with
no intention
he's doing like you light he's in the
states and he's in his own car but you
go to like like like Zimbabwe and then
you just go like with no shoes yeah yeah
is he really going for no intention yeah
he does that once a while he's like in
Des Moines or something yeah for no
reason he was in St Charles whatever or
something the other day and then he's
like I'll figure out where I'm going
next oh
yeah
it wasn't really it was like it was like
I'm like I'm like
the new wife running into the ex-wife
so I was like hey but I felt a little
uncomfortable no you didn't I did no I
did I felt a little awkward I felt a
little awkward well you guys have the
same hair
um especially that text I just sent you
because I'm trying to join the band oh
yeah yeah
Hollywood Hollywood's a mess I need I
need a stable don't don't I feel don't
tell me that because I'm being serious
you're not
I am but it's a lot of work isn't it
yeah but you don't have to do the work
come in and you know get me in there
you'll want to do the work you'll want
you no how many how many months a year
do you shoot like I cap it it's we cap
it at six we try to get in under six you
shoot six months out of the year now we
used to shoot nine to ten Jesus
oh it needs to be 31 episodes now he's
doing only 18.
and but 31 episodes a season yeah 26 and
five specials we did that for like eight
years dude I look at me I do ten
[Laughter]
who thinks I should join the Impractical
Joker everybody you are the you are the
next game
okay you're the next person run into Joe
but six months out of the year I need I
mean I need time I need my rest so so
here's the thing we don't film every day
it's not like it's not like we don't
Bank we don't just film every day we
film we shoot like on a slow week one or
two days a week on a busy week four on
an average we spend three days a week
and then the other days if there's
production meetings and things like that
every week or you got hiatus's building
no we got uh every six weeks I think we
have a week down and uh it's a lot of
work and then we have off like we put in
when we need off before the season
starts and we build around that
so what if I wanted to go off and do
something
shoot something I bet you that we could
I'm serious I'm talking this out loud
right now live but don't don't Loop in
the other guys
[Laughter]
would you do it part-time yeah tell us
when you're available now the strikes
yeah are you guys are you're not allowed
people there's no trouble at all you
could do a non-union show I'll do your
show as much I love your show I'll do
your show as much as you want me
flattered that you I know I love I I
your show got me through quarantine I
would watch it just obsessively it's the
it's like that's like a trip to the spa
for me well because I just love watching
pranks yeah and you guys have so such a
massive body of work I would never see a
repeat yeah I was like these guys are
prolific well I would watch it every day
there was never been a repeat and pranks
are so hard you well I'm like how do you
[__] do so many gods sing it sister
thank you you're here thank you you know
and and you guys are sweethearts thank
you and you are too people think you're
a zany Wild guy which you are yeah but
you're one of the sweetest people I've
ever met the only the craziest thing I
that ever happened to me my sister came
at me with the Barbie doll to scratched
my eye and now every time I see the
Barbie movie my eyes starts twitching
son of a [__] that happened to me
I made a mistake of telling him that one
time when we were in the makeup chair
and I forgot I told him and then like he
brought it up and I was like how do you
know this yes I was like how do you
notice he's like I know stuff because
it's like how would you know this
you see that [__] right you see that you
see that red mark yeah yeah that's her
that's cancer yeah I know I say tourism
she's in Jersey
date your sister
okay sitcom all right what's the
motivation my sister's is your sister
married she's single no my sister's
single oh my sister's married it'll be
even that's a better even yeah even even
that was like me running into Joe in the
hallway
um well you well you are literally
co-hosting the cruise with us yeah I
mean it's the impressive jokes and Eric
Andre Cruz it's uh January in uh 20
seconds it's gonna be okay so we've done
and they're insane already they're
insane yeah it's a lot of fun a lot of
good people on boat a lot of great
comics and it's just it's it's this is
why I'm scared it's Reef roll it's like
there's no rules we're at Sea and
everyone's just partying and
international waters it's international
waters maritime law and now you add you
to what I already know did you come to
my birthday party every year you have it
you you and my mom are on the same day
your birthday is April 4th yeah every
year that you have it
um I have legit of excuses
on the road book like specifically
because this I would claw tooth and nail
to make it you would have to go there's
obligations I can't get out of but your
party isn't have you heard about his
party
tell them about
birthday part every year and it's it is
the most crazy thing I've ever heard out
of any party I've ever heard in my
entire life though in my entire life
like I feel like terrible to miss it
like I want to cancel contracts to see
it so once before I went did them
publicly were even crazy crazier we
would like Huff ether and throw
firecrackers out and we have like camels
and it was like a zoo yeah and it was
none of that that's just like some of
the hundred things like in my little
apartment I had a little apartment in
Hollywood off uh off like uh Wilcox and
Santa Monica it was like the size of
this room and I would cram like you
didn't have a [__] thousands of
people y'all get the camel in there we
were huffing either and ether's
flammable I don't even know throwing
firecrackers outside doing whip it was
crazy he's scared he's scared to go on
the cruise
this is why I'm scared I'm worried it's
gonna be like my birthday but like for
how many days is it five days six days
it's four nights five days four nights
five afterwards sorry after my birthday
after my birthday foreign
after one day yeah I'm like toast for
the rest of the week yeah you have to
you have you cannot function host so
doing that four nights five nights in a
row I feel like I'm gonna it's a
marathon you have to you have to
I'll be your spiritual guy
I know dude I'll be your guy but you
need
yeah they're a handsy people they're
gonna grab you um
my first
show on the season four tour I crowd
surfed right off the bat and you were
someone masturbated you to ejaculation
no worse Okay Okay jump out I'm crowd
surfing yeah this kid underneath me
sticks all four fingers up my ass crack
another kid grabs my penis and testicles
as hard as he were you naked no in my
clothes okay but he's like cramming his
[__] but a thin little tuxedo whatever
yeah cramming his fingers up my ass
another kid grabs my penis and testicles
as hard as he can another kid sucks his
pinky gives me a wet willy this is all
in 10 seconds another kid grabs a hot
dog off the ground shoves it in the back
of my mouth and then the rest of the
crowd starts drawing and quartering my
limbs in different directions and then I
finally did like Street karate got to
the ground and then this kid was chasing
me and fighting me and I went boom and I
punch him in the stomach you're kidding
me dude and he was like anyway yeah
I like I loved it and I crawled back to
the stage like oh like terrified for my
life and that was the first 30 seconds
of the show the first show of the tour
yeah and then I started my monologue I
was like
so oh this was at a show this wasn't
even a birthday party this was just not
a regular show
what are you doing did they get thrown
out were you upset with you like I asked
for it that was like like it would have
been half the crowd was thrown out if I
did it right on glass bottles at the
show during the show I was like they
could start just chucking it was in
Vancouver they're gonna Chuck Le Bat
Blue Box yeah so they are fans but like
they're like like they're back there but
they were like let's destroy it let's
eat them alive and then you got back on
stage and then you you did it you were
able to like recalibrate yeah but I was
like I never I've never crowd surfed
ever again yeah that was probably like
five years I've only crowd surfed them
well actually yeah
but besides that I crowd surfed uh two
times maybe three all were good
experiences this was a nightmare this
was a nightmare and the cruise is gonna
be like that now I'm getting you worried
you were trying to calm me down if you
see me I literally I feel the flutter of
anxiety just now my [__] I felt I
went like I could take a breath like
so I was like
yeah well we can't say it yeah yeah we
can't say it sorry you'll cut that out
is it Live Well we don't you're bringing
the craziest we might have we do have to
be because we don't know it's not signed
it so if he doesn't do it you know but
no but no but we do that out yes but but
just let you know if you bring him to
and bring his fans yeah and my fans so
and your fans yeah it's gonna be
[Music]
the first four years I brought my family
like my extended family I don't know if
I should this year I'm afraid I'm gonna
be like at nudity everywhere I'm gonna
be naked half the time but I'm gonna be
ex I'm gonna be drained there might be
something down there though there might
be some kids on it okay well we gotta
have R-rated yeah whatever
I'm
if this isn't intriguing you guys
because look the
75 sold out maybe maybe less and uh this
isn't intriguing you we didn't even
announce the major action and there's
someone else that might be coming on
here that is definitely in the same DNA
as us
and if that person comes on it's just
going to be like it's fomo you can't
miss something like this it's going to
be like a once in a but I'm more I'm
even you're exciting me this is my fifth
one and I always love doing that's why I
still do it because it's it I do at the
end of it I have no voice ever and I I
like get carried off that thing I swear
to God it's inevitable right but you
have a time of your life but like now
with the work though the wild card that
is you you can put in as much as you
want into it and out of it I always do
110 percent
well good for you
you could do you could do whatever
percentage you want just like you I'm
doing 75
70. just like when you become doing 75
just like when you become a cast man I'm
Jokers you're already looking for a way
you're 30 but um
but I'm I'm getting excited and
interested and curious about my own our
own Cruise because the wild card that
you are and what mixing these two things
together is going to do if you bring
that third guy on it's gonna be [__]
crazy you guys don't but don't what I
don't want we can't start bringing each
other
[Music]
your life's over because not only will
he prank you at work
sneak into your home at three in the
morning he broke into my house one time
but he'll start putting rat traps in
your mailbox you'll go in and grab your
mail yeah your phone finger will be
broken no that's not what I do yeah it's
crazy that's not what I do I can't do it
you know you put your hand on something
you have my word as long as we don't
break the word I can trust you trust me
no no no yeah it gets it gets and I've
never formally met this potential guest
but we've always almost met and uh I'm
excited to meet him I'm a fan but like
I'm hoping that we all make this pact
with each other because you know that I
I don't want to be a nightmare on that I
want to have fun
let's just say who it is it's Jared from
Subway
[Laughter]
we mixed him in jodarosa up and we're
trying to get him on oh God we're trying
to get him on the cruise there's some
surprises coming like you just mentioned
DeRosa I can't say whether he might be
on or not or maybe I love the real
something I said that he's not here and
I'm I'm I'm I dearly miss him yes
something might happen on that cruise
too I can't say what but there might be
some some live something or others on
there we can't announce anything yet
really right
we can't even announce
your boy either not yet not until they
said we can't announce yet they want to
just make it they didn't announce that
yet right
you I'm
me no you
my cousin
paulenka Esparza oh oh he's coming on
you're crazy right now yes son of a
[__] you're busting my balls are you
busting my balls
he's your right hand man I love him
will you do a live would you do a live
have you met him no I kept so excited to
meet him dude everyone I everyone I say
that he's coming everyone has nothing
but great things to say about he's like
my favorite I love I can't wait to meet
him are you so we're performing we're
we're doing like a bunch of headline
shows for everybody and so are you are
you just gonna be doing like stand up
are you gonna do like what are you gonna
is there any way that like you do like a
like a live like like I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do it yeah I'm gonna do the Eric
Andre show live basically oh you are
yeah oh yeah oh that's gonna fill up the
cruise no it's gonna be a mess and are
you doing that like main deck or do you
know what you're doing that yet are you
doing that in the theater okay I want to
know I don't know the different parts
can I be honest you know yeah but be
careful what you wish I've always wanted
to be on your show I would never invited
everyone come on in
be careful what you be careful what you
asked for folks Joe DeRosa here want to
talk to you about a new sponsor here at
the taste buds podcast hero bread I love
hero bread why do I love it well number
one I love bread I love bread being
fluffy I love bread being soft I love
bread being delicious and tasty and
guess what hero bread is absolutely all
of those things but herobrad also has
fewer calories than the leading National
brand it's got five to ten grams of
protein per serving it's high in fiber
it's ultra low in net carbs and it's got
zero grams of sugar per slice so it's
bread even better
who who doesn't want that I know I do
that's why I ate it and I think you do
too which is why I want you to pursue
this wonderful offer herobrad is
offering the listeners of taste buds
right now listeners of this show you can
get 10 off your first order all you got
to do is go to hero.co and use promo
code taste buds to get 10 off your first
order and save on hero bread today they
got buns they got sliced breads they got
tortillas go to h-e-r-o dot Co and save
10 percent today hey don't you dare skip
this okay this weekend September 8th I'm
at the Syracuse Funny Bone for the
weekend and then I'm rounding that off
in September going to Bowling Green
Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio and Toledo Ohio
and there's more dates on and on through
December uh savvalcanocomedy.com right
now Syracuse I'll see you this coming
weekend also Sal vulcano official on
YouTube please subscribe uh once a week
starting in two weeks I'm going to be
giving away a prize ever every single
week to only the people that are
subscribed to my YouTube I'm pulling the
winners from there it could be anything
from a prop from the show free tickets
to see me autograph posters of set visit
and actually if we get to 500 000
subscribers I will pull a winner out of
those subscribers to go to dinner with
me and Joe Gatto so that's that also if
you haven't got it get
shipfacedcruise.com come on the
Impractical Jokers and Eric Andre Cruz
in January 2024 we're almost sold out
check that out everything's available
right now sabalcano comedy.com and we're
making tickets a little more affordable
because I want to reach all of my
audience so if you you know if you're on
a budget check it out there's tickets
for you as well
September 16th Avenal New Jersey
September 21st through the 23rd Toronto
uh September 29th through October 1st
I'll be at skank Fest not doing the hour
there but I'll be there and I hope to
see you uh November 11th Philadelphia
Pennsylvania theater of the Living Arts
November 17th Pittsburgh PA November
18th Buffalo New York November 30th
Denver Colorado December 1st Phoenix
Arizona December 3rd Salt Lake City my
gosh my gosh my gosh we have so much
going on and this just in October 28th
here in New York City at Arlene's
grocery salsa windfall first live show
in 20 years people who's joining us well
maybe
esoterica dj7 out of Czar face is going
to be joining us who else is joining us
the stumble bums who else is joining us
we'll see you in hell live it's going to
be a Halloween bash more acts are being
announced it is an event an event an
event October 28th we want to see you
there and before you come make sure you
cop that new saucer windfall album
artificial birth available on all
streaming platforms now we hope to see
you people and I always I also I also
hope to see you Joey roses
and sandwich place down to the Lower
East Side of New York Joey roses
joeyroses.com we're open seven days a
week I'll see you there and that's where
the After parties happen on October 28th
boom
yeah but like you you've been on our
show twice I want you to be on more you
might become a part-time cast member
like I'll do it but six months out of
the year no no part-time can you okay
how about this here's where it's tough
if you're on like if you have to be on
in order to compete for the if it makes
sense of the punishment you gotta
participate in the things before that
punishment so just coming in random here
and there and being in episode you could
do it but then the man be chunks maybe I
do right so if you can say like oh I can
do this month and that month like that
we're working out of the scheduling
because I want you to come on I really
do I know no I would love to I'm just
saying I think your fans are like the
eyes glazed over like are they working
on their calendars together I think
they're
there
enough make it so that we can get in
certain full completed episodes in that
time so if there's 18 episodes and you
want to be on five we'll work it out no
where there's a will there's a way yeah
because I really would like to dig in
there with you too because a lot of
times we're on borrowed time when you
come no no no I got nothing going on now
well yeah so everything's on hold then
everything are you gonna so what are you
gonna do now tour or what are you doing
yes
write a book that's all I could do right
and you're doing you do the pot out of
here now right
yeah yeah
oh you do yeah oh that's where Joe and
Steve Byrne do theirs I did it yesterday
so you'll run into yeah
but you're giving us the runarounds
I only work in truths so there's no way
there's no way you've been trying your
team is giving me the runner my team
texts me my team who am I you
you text you don't text me back I text
you you don't text me back
I invite you to my birthday you don't
come that I really want to go to can you
tell me when you're going to have it
next year
but you do it on day of every year no
matter
all right so this is what I'm asking if
you could if you can Target the weekend
I'll block that [__]
I'll fly out there
okay what he did was he took it from
that from his house and now he literally
sells tickets it's a ticketed event yeah
and he has his party and dude I mean we
might we might have some of the people
from your crazy party on the cruise
right yeah yeah so that's gonna be a lot
of fun yeah you can't you came here on
taste buds we do battles okay we do salt
versus pepper we try to talk we tried to
talk
I tried to give you a I left you a voice
message I tried to give you a briefing
of what we do I was eating Korean food
on the exhausted and you were like I
don't I don't necessarily understand
what you're saying yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I was all right so we didn't
pick them out just a three minute
voicemail yeah yeah yeah it's a long
that's a long time I understand more
than 30 seconds that's pretty crazy I
was in an Uber and I have ADHD and I'm
on medication now so I've been focusing
really okay you got Adderall I need to
get medicine I went through Adderall one
two three and four then I went to
concert the doses oh yeah to see how
they would work because I'm trying
desperately because I have a terrible
ADHD then I moved on to Concerta I did
all four doses it's like Adderall then
I'm on another one now
I'm on the fourth highest dose of that
right now so I've tried four three
different medications 12 different doses
over the last five months so I'm just
trying to somehow find a breakthrough
with this antidepressant medications I'm
also on Paxil no Wellbutrin yeah I was
thinking about starting Zoloft I wrote
that I was on vacation I was in Sardinia
I woke up in the middle of the night I
wrote down Zoloft dog girlfriend get
these three things
well dog stuff you're always on you're
not at home a lot yeah but a girlfriend
really because I always just see you uh
I'm kissing I'm kissing right there I'm
making out yeah
you're right I need to pick I need to
give one gal of the road and you and you
you are a very high profile guy
you dip in and out of high profile
dating situations I should say
isn't that crazy like I'm a normal
fellow you know I've been with the same
lady for like over 10 years and I have
more color I have more of a life yes I
do my old lady
um I have more of a regular scenario
going I need a more regular
you live a life that is very interesting
I'm very tired very controlled and tired
you're jet setting everywhere I mean
InterContinental I mean globally jet
setting and then every time I I don't
see you for a while I know who you're
dating because I see it online and a lot
of times you're very upfront with it you
don't know who I'm dating now I would
love to know you want to know who yes I
do Janet Reno wow she's alive still yeah
really
is he alive so she just pegs you and
then yeah yeah
not but nothing those glasses are
actually in style now if you live in
like Brooklyn
um I got a question for you yeah
why can't you find love
never been to Italy yeah I've been there
once yeah it's beautiful yeah a mouthy
that's I haven't really been further
than that
I went to like Positano and all those
areas over there but I went to Sardinia
recently and I went to Lago was it
amazing it's amazing you went alone with
the secret girl I went with a secret
girl now was the secretary
first jaunt with her like the first
vacation together
I met a gal well I met an Italian gal
while you were out there huh and then
she stayed with you for the trip oh no
you met an Italian girl and you went to
go
there is a sanctity to the privacy of no
I'm not my romantic Affairs and that's
why you can give me whatever crumbs you
want I'm looking for crumbs I'm looking
for a little something
so let me ask you a question how do you
meet these women and then how do you
Craigslist so quickly how do you date
these women so quickly and then also is
it an amicable split of sorts or what's
happening here
I'm just talking about your general your
general you know
life like you know like you you I see
you you know I see you nude online
you know with everyone you're nude
everywhere with everyone and then by the
next time I see you I say how's that
person you're nude with and you're like
they're they're great people and uh I'm
nude with someone else I am practicing
celibacy okay
and I'm never gonna have
sex again until I'm married
do you think you're gonna get married
one day yeah you do think you believe do
you in Your Heart of Heart by the end of
this year I will be married
and that's my guarantee you'll be up to
the American you'll be a cast member on
Jokers you will get married I am a I I
can I've married 11 people I've married
I married Joe and his wife I married you
yeah yeah I married I I married friends
I kind of semi retired I retired I will
come out of retirement I married my
sister I will come out in my room my
assistant married your sister very much
tell me about your romantic Affairs
um I will marry you um to whoever you
you end up choosing uh and we could do
it on the cruise and you said by the end
of the year right which means you'll be
engaged which means January 22nd to the
26th I'll get married on the cruise and
I will I will marry you officially on
that cruise I have a license it'll be
fully real really yes okay you can find
a lifelong Love Affair by then
first person I get pregnant I'm gonna
marry okay
do you feel like you'll have kids one
day listen these are all gonna be you're
making these facts you're making these
facts right now
why is it what why is it hard for other
contrary to find love okay you know what
what is going on no well you know what I
never really dated
no
is it the nature of your career is it is
it is it just like you're someone never
really
um
settled down until recently okay yeah
well that makes sense I mean it's so
you've you've reached a point where
you're thinking about that seriously now
yeah okay I'm thinking about another
more okay serious and long term who's
this Italian
Sal it is so good seeing you
it's so good seeing you man yeah yeah so
good hanging out with you so it's a
proper European Italian
that's that's exotic
you're exotic you know you're in you're
exotic too you're an exotic mix you guys
all kind of congregates against all the
Exotics
yeah we're not even battling are we
gonna battle anything I have a question
yeah ghost experiences you believe
you believe oh that's a great question
Bart believe it in ghost versus not
believing in ghost can you put up a poll
so I don't have to do it we'll get a few
hundred you know do you believe would
you not believe that's a total battle I
don't believe but
yeah that's a good answer yeah I want to
believe in ghosts yeah I don't
but I want I want to you know what I
mean because it's just exciting it's fun
it feels like there's Limitless ghost
experiences and encounters from people
yet there's never like a ghost but why
wouldn't it be a ghost experience right
now
it's always alone it's always alone
because the ghost that got unfinished
business yeah yeah but the ghosts that
have an experience they're
procrastinating they were
procrastinating in their real life and
they're taking it out on me like I don't
give a [__] be an unfinished business
yeah should have finished it while you
were alive pal
you know what I mean would you would you
be like so so you think ghosts because
then there's religion like we're a ghost
like like just Spirits hovering around
and we don't believe in in religion and
that's what's happening with ghosts
you understand like what is a ghost like
will you become a ghost and if you
became a ghost well here's my issue with
ghosts they're only they only look like
that they're only from like the
Victorian era they're only from like
like the 1800s yeah like why can't David
Bowie flow through here yeah exactly
but like Mike drop it
yeah but why that harambe just
but honestly like I don't do haunted
houses like I don't I'm sorry no I got
too much anxiety same same so I am
scared too much anxiety I don't believe
it but
taste Babas you know this show is
sponsored by better help uh look if
you've benefited from therapy in the
past we've always talked about better
help feel free to uh to try this out I
mean it's different it's it's online
it's entirely online with licensed
professionals okay and you know
basically it's the convenient of your
own home it's easy you could switch
therapists at any time you just fill out
a brief questionnaire and you're on your
way uh you know I don't know these days
and uh this day and age I truly I feel
like I don't know if it's just me but
there's a lot more stressors and I'm in
a point in my life where I definitely
want to make the right decisions and go
down the right path and sometimes you
know you need a little help with that
and that's one of the ways that better
help Can Help Therapy gives you a place
to do that so you can get out of your
negative thought cycles and find some
mental and emotional peace if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try again it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule so you fill out that
questionnaire you match with the
therapist and you could switch them
anytime at no additional charge it's
really there's no harm in trying this
out guys get a break from your thoughts
um with better help visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds to get 10 off your first month
today visit betterhelp.com taste buds
that's be better help
hclp.com taste buds taste Buddies the
game time app I use it all the time I
love it I'm so happy they're um
sponsoring the podcast if you don't know
what it is because you don't listen all
the time you should but it is basically
an app that lets you uh get last minute
tickets at amazing deals for the lowest
price guaranteed all on the app all
delivered right to your phone in a
matter of seconds couple of clicks and
that's it it's tickets to everything
it's not just Sports it's concerts it's
events it is plays everything you think
of uh ticket buying has been a stressful
thing basically historically and
nowadays people aren't planning months
in advance like this so if you want to
get killer deals on last minute tickets
at the best price guaranteed and stop
stressing you get the game time app they
have some pretty cool features you get
images of your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive like I said two Taps and you get
the tickets and also there's a game time
guarantee and this is pretty big it
means you'll always get the best price
and if you find tickets in the same
section or row four less game time will
credit you 110 of that difference it
really make it easy to like snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app today
create an account and use code taste
buds for twenty dollars off your first
purchase terms apply again just create
an account and redeem code taste buds
for 20 off your first purchase download
the game time app today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
you think I should stop drinking
[Laughter]
take me through um a week of drinking I
don't drink every night but it's just
like it's just bad for you it just makes
me feel like crap yeah I I started to
feel that way not you know as well and I
for the most part I stopped drinking I
have it's fun that's a wine at dinner
yeah or like maybe like maybe a martini
before dinner or a glass of wine during
dinner when I go out right maybe at home
maybe if I go out on my Terrace it's a
beautiful night I I have a couple of
glasses don't drink me I drop weight my
skin looks better my hair looks better
on bags under my eyes same it's just
like I'm like it's I have this weird
cognitive distance now I'm like
you also go hard in every direction so
when you're drinking you drink and when
you're not drinking you look you have
like washboard abs and it's insane too
and then you say you hate that too
though because of the hard work that was
a lot of work yeah it's not worth it and
there's no communic value in a guy with
the washboard apps no but we've got to
either be too skinny or pudgy right
that's it for comedians story of my life
you can
be gaunt and you can be pudgy yeah you
can't be you can't be ripped I'm trying
to work on a new thing like a gaunt
pudge
really I think that's how you would
describe it
um when you drink
um do you do you tie it on all the time
or is it like no can you drink in
moderation I never got I never get like
black out what's your drink of choice
I like rum I can see that love rum
exotic pirate exotic Caribbean speaking
of pirates and ships get shipfaced
cruise.com yeah baby book a cabin on
this Cruise yeah that is going to sell
out January what are you doing in
January that's like the dearth of the
year it's like gray and stupid come to
the tropics there you go yeah absolutely
he's getting married on it that's right
yeah I know but I do now but you I did
that three times weed weed came into my
life in 2018. 2018 you didn't smoke
until 2018. correct yeah I mean in my
life I I did but like I never bought it
I didn't know how to get it I didn't
practice it I never had it in my
possession it was always just like a
thing really yeah then 2018 uh when that
this cough yeah for seven years
um
you don't smoke no
you should go to the doctor for that I
went to the doctor I had an inhaler kind
of went away it kind of comes back you
got like a post nasal drip maybe I don't
know yeah something post nasal drip or
you got allergies asthma that's bad
something I don't know you gotta go you
got to figure this out you have a doctor
I need a doctor I do
I'm I'm worse than that I don't like to
go to doctors that I don't know in
offices I don't know and my friend from
high school became a a doctor and he
lives in Nashville and he's specialized
in sports medicine but he took me on as
a client so when I had to go to the
doctor I just zoomed my friend from
Nashville really yeah
that's shout out Jim that's um
what was your last checkup I gotta go
get the colonoscopy and the prostate
yeah first time in my life I didn't do
all that I'm scheduling it now
did you go under I went under for the
colonoscopy endoscopy it's nothing
you're out but were you alone
I was alone you have a partner there or
something like a witness I was alone I
just feel weird but it was in an
Alleyway in Tijuana
and I've never walked straight I've been
walking crooked ever since no uh no it
was a reputable GI doctor who's up the
street no big deal in and out showed me
that put under he showed me the the
video and the pictures that I'm great
well the prep work was that hard and
then my and then the prostate
same guy no that's my doc that's my
regular doctor I can't double up I'd
like to get it done in one shot maybe
but my doctor I went for my yearly
physical and my doctor goes oh big
birthday this year you turn 40 I go yeah
he goes you know what that means
snapped on the glove I go it was oh yeah
moment yeah I go you gotta check it he
goes bend over and I was like
doc I'm fine you don't have to whoa
well actually I kind of respect that
yeah yeah he made it he like made it
like you know he like he's just like
yeah come on let's do it yeah yeah he's
like he's like and he goes you're
healthy yeah yeah yeah what was that
like I mean you've had other hard as I
ever yeah yeah you've had other fingers
up there you've had you've had all sorts
of Italian fingers up there you're
intrigued but it's a diet pill you like
that I'm uh hanging out with your tribe
huh I only have
what's the other oh the other Puerto
Rican Cuban yeah you ever been to Puerto
Rico or Cuba no I tried to go to Cuba uh
a few years ago actually but then
something happened and like something
happened and it got harder again because
of something that happened yeah
something politically it happened to the
federal government yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the executive branch of the federal
government yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
couldn't go then but uh I went to Cuba
you're the last guy do you love it
one of the best trips in my life yeah I
heard it I heard it's like never been to
Puerto Rico Time Capsule down there yeah
it's insane yes one of the most
beautiful countries I've ever been to
yeah I gotta go just for the feeling of
like seeing the people that remind me of
my garage
yeah that's why you're on [__] crazy
pills you're like you gotta work yeah
crazy pills
to be established having something crazy
amount of pills crazy
crazy
[Laughter]
I gotta get some of those pills man yeah
no you don't oh you know what we I want
some I want something for the anxiety
Xanax I want I want just I gotta do it
from the first time that we ever met
years ago we've been talking about doing
mushrooms together and every time I'm
going down to Peru to Ayahuasca I can't
do that
you you can do whatever you want to do
man how do you find the time to go to
you got a job you got money go go to
Peru this is what you do you go on
kayak.com you type in Peru and then you
type buy the ticket it's like ordering
socks on Amazon you you do that's what
I'm saying you do this like you're
ordering socks that's how you make it
but Woody Wilson what else do you need
but let me ask you questions who
actually like helps plan this trip for
you me no but like where you're going
where you're staying like what are you
gonna do like when you went to like the
last time I saw you leaving for South
Africa or something like that yeah
remember regular regular Africa
and then you were like I'm going here
here here here's a great resource I have
it's called google.com really and I just
do research when I ask Friends Ask
friends how was that trip to Africa the
trip of a lifetime really trip of a
lifetime all right and crying every day
yeah well I do that here and I'm not
joking
I'm not joking at all literally not
joking cried every day this week but uh
but um this week particularly stressful
no
yeah no no every week every week is
particularly stressed yeah yeah yeah
um you you life's not all about work
this is what I learned I know I learned
in Italy
they go you Americans you guys all live
to work we work we work to live we work
so we can live you guys live to work we
work so we can live 1 p.m you know what
happens they take a siesta they don't
work till 4 pm they go they jump in the
ocean they eat they take a nap then they
slowly make their way back to work four
to eight then at eight everything shuts
down they eat a delicious meal they have
a glass of wine that's the way to go
they make a the love I know they like
cigarettes they make love they love
cigarettes over there I'm not gonna do
cigarettes enough they smoke is someone
going with you to the Ayahuasca Peru I'm
going by myself
you know what's his name from the he's
on the Jets now Aaron Rodgers he did
that like uh no talking Retreat alone
yeah I've done one of those silent
Meditation Retreat what did Catman do
Nepal
yeah I went to a monastery but you see
what a Buddhist Monastery and then you
didn't speak
there was no talking in the morning it
was like half day silent meditation you
couldn't do the full you go to Bhutan
and you lie like you sleep on a piece of
wood and you don't talk for 15 days you
can do that but where does that yeah
where does that like so how was your
experience with the no talking
meditation
it was great you're doing all of these
insanely
like Pro like just profound life type of
experiences well life is short you got
occur you gotta I understand this
experience and when you come away from
these things are you changed every time
you come back I think so yeah yeah you
kind of like you feel like an evolution
of your of yourself yeah the way you the
way you think or process things or
that's amazing I was talking to uh
yesterday about this I was gonna build a
home I'm in the process of building a
home and it's like over budget and it's
stressing me out and everything in
Staten Island what I'm where I'm
building it I won't say oh oh oh yeah
okay I just because it's your privacy
whatever but
uh yeah but um where I'm building it I
want to be doing two podcasts today you
you can't you said I gotta leave it too
that's in two and a half minutes
oh do you want to do my other one the
60-second podcast
what's the other one you do have to
leave in two and a half minutes right
the other one is with Krista Stefano
it's called hey babe I wanted to do that
one it starts in two and a half minutes
it's up to you I don't know I gotta be
at Simon and Schuster 2 30. yeah that's
not gonna happen that's not gonna happen
but you know life's not all about work
you know
okay what are you gonna say you're gonna
say I was gonna say no I was gonna say
serious considerations about building
like something for like less than half
that cost and retiring
wait wait say that again I'm considering
like building something like way way way
way less of cost than that so it's just
because it was it's not even a
consideration of the cost of building
the house I'm building now oh and then
just retiring yeah just doing stand up
but that's it and then just staying and
literally going into retirement right
now because I am having a midlife crisis
and I just feel like I want to you're
not alone yeah okay thank you you're not
alone I mean no really people are like
people around the world are questioning
the grind of I think that
the surreal suspended animation of
quarantining yeah made everybody assess
everything yeah and
and just like all right you're on my age
like I'm older than you you just turned
40. yeah we're the same age nah babe
we're the same age November I'll be 47.
you're 47 I think you're 43. I'm 46
being gonna be 47.
I look I love I look gone
but
that's not all about work you know I
think you're on to something
it might only be who knows if there's
going to be how much longer we'll do
this show so you come on part-time on
Jokers I will work this out with you if
you're serious I you know I'll do it I'm
not gonna make sure you're willing to
have me and as much as my schedule okay
okay
I'm noted noted I've been trying to get
on that show for years
I can get two episodes and then you
treat me like yesterday's lunch
[Music]
[Laughter]
not sure you know uh we do come back if
we do
um we're gonna not we're not doing the
guests
anymore because they had they're having
budget cuts and we need to cut a lot and
that was the first thing they were like
well do we really need that and we're
like it is hard it makes it harder
because we have to write for that guest
and then we have to go according to
their schedule but we're all location
dependent so it's like this jigsaw
puzzle it's a main contention for stress
so we were like all right we'll we'll
let that go but we'll just have guests
randomly when we want so yeah but you
could be a cast member great yeah I'm
just speaking for everyone because I
know though I know they'll want to thank
you no saying oh it's done
all right I know you got to go and I
don't want you to be late I wanted to do
your other podcast
I know
well tell Simon shoots to 3 30. no I was
late yesterday and I took my time and
now I gotta get out there all right I
want to ask you about the Ayahuasca
because I wanna I've been thinking about
doing that too but I'm very am I always
scared iOS I'm not not scared I think
the fear of it is part of it you've done
it never done it oh it's gonna be a
first time thing I spoke I've smoked
Buffalo various toad Venom which is a
DMT derivative but I've never done
ayahuasca
but I smoke toad Venom in Mexico it was
the highest
I have ever been or anyone on Earth has
ever been in their entire life it was
full brain Factor did you know you were
gonna do it or did it happen in the
moment no no I knew I was gonna do it
why
you did the answer sad okay
my dad died my dad died in December okay
this is doing the taste buds
[Laughter]
I'm sorry that's why I'm doing all this
spiritual stuff okay that's why I'm
doing the toad Venom and I went to
Africa okay
turning 40. it's like my dad died then I
turned 40. so yeah I can't even deal I'm
worried about all that [__] you know
what I mean yeah yeah all right well uh
you know maybe thanks for bringing it up
I I want to try you you inspired me I'm
gonna try to do something out of the box
experience life experience life is short
you gotta
do it right I mean you're gonna did you
fart no I burped
I moved forward I got bad heartburn man
I would just tell you I just but I did
burp
I burp all day you don't burp
I burp man yeah I burp I burp we're
gonna have to cut all this out right
bourbon I got crazy stalkers I don't
want them to know I burp okay
spot I want you to come back I want to
go on your pod
I want you to come on the show part time
uh I want you to let me know when your
birthday party is gonna be next year so
I can block it out I want to smoke a
derivation of toad blood and uh
anything you want to plug at all like
anything
I got a tour go to Eric Andre tour.com
yeah that's a big one come see me come
see me in a city near you I'm gonna
um do a live tour and uh destroy every
venue I go to absolutely and you're
gonna finish it off with the high seas
at the crew did you just fart
get shipfacecrews.com January 22nd to
the 26th 2024 from Miami to the Bahamas
it's not to be missed
I love you Sal on my podcast that's why
I came on it I got a podcast I got a
podcast called bombing I want you on no
I didn't tell my mom we'll do it we'll
do it but for real that's good because
we saved it just text me I really
there's no dude there's no big I come on
come on you gotta get his team it's like
I gotta meet like a guy from CAA on a
helicopter that's not even sure I love
you thanks for making the time for today
when you had a meeting though for real
of course
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them